our next speaker is muhammad kazeem
shirani
he is a postdoc at the department of
statistics in university of florida
and currently a research fellow in the
reinforcement learning program muhammad
will join university of georgia as
assistant professor
in statistics in the coming
thank you prasad
hopefully you can hear me uh
yes yeah okay thank you yeah uh so
this uh this is a short explanation
about the linear quadratic reinforcement
learning problem
uh in number one we have uh the dynamics
of the environment
so basically the problem is that uh this
is a decision-making problem
dealing with an environment which is
unknown the
uncertainty about the environment is
being uh reflected in
equation in number one the linear
dynamics
which uh maps states and actions
to the next state actually and
this is actually a stochastic one with
noise
the goal is to maximize reward number
four which is
quadratic which has a quadratic form of
both the state and action
uh because we do not know the dynamics
matrices they go
they need to be uh estimated um
so here's the problem uh the classical
reinforcement learning
setting that we want to maximize the
reward and we also want to
learn the unknown uh underlying
environment
the reason for considering this problem
as a classic one is uh
being reflected in number seven that the
optimal action
is uh has a linear form of the estate at
the time
and uh as a usual metric of the
performance rigorously being considered
as a gap between our reward and the
reward of the optimal policy
so let me skip the details and go
through the next slide
which is a very new algorithm which has
been there for only
25 centuries which is greedy algorithm
and
it's an episodic one that during every
episode
uh we stick with some policy some
linear function of uh state as being
taken as action
and at the end of episodes the update of
the unknown environment
matrices a hat and b hat colored in red
they are being updated
so this is 3d algorithm the length of
the episodes can grow
up to exponentially fast um
the only thing is that we change this we
modify this algorithm somehow
that we uh that this vista square
estimation at the end of episodes will
be
a little bit modified to address the
uh the very famous trade-off of
exploration and exploitation
so far could you please go to the next
slide so
the algorithm is a very classic one the
problem is a classic one the only
novelty lies in the
modifications of this algorithm and in
the analysis
let me first tell you the analysis there
are four different
uh uh modifications
to try to balance the exploration and
exploitation
if at least one of them is being
employed
the regret scales as a square root of
time and also the quality of learning
the unknown underlying environment is as
specified according to the number of
samples so uh in the interest of time
let me
rush over these four different uh
modifications of the greedy least square
algorithm one of them is to perturb
the action by some small perturbation
diminishing over time
the uh this is number one and the
magnitude of the
perturbation is being uh specified there
in red
the second one is randomizing this
gradient algorithm by adding some random
matrices to our list square estimation
the third one is samsung sampling to
form a cluster your belief
around the uh according to the using the
data to form a
posterior belief around the um
listed square estimate and then sampling
from this normal distribution
and finally booster put a strap in the
sense that
before we find the residuals and the
estimations of the
the unknown dynamics according to the
data we use these residuals and the
estimation
to form some new fake data and use the
fake data to draw some bootstrap
approximation these these four
modifications are actually solving the
problem for us thank you